on this tuesday night historic
injustices historic reparations
this is the largest settlement in
canadian history ottawa's 40 billion
dollar compensation deal for indigenous
children harmed by the child welfare
system we needed the canadian public to
awaken to the injustices
code orange we are facing unprecedented
challenges the intensifying coveted
crisis at two ontario hospitals
stranded overnight the highway that's
turned into a parking lot for hundreds
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
after years of failing to act the
federal government today released
details of an agreement to compensate
first nations children and their
families harmed by the underfunding of
the child welfare system on reserves
tens of thousands of children who were
removed from their homes forced into
foster care often move multiple times
losing connection to their families and
culture and leading to a legacy of loss
and harm it is the largest class action
settlement in canadian history worth 40
billion dollars it will be split into 20
billion for compensation and 20 billion
for long-term reform of the on reserve
child welfare system it means the
government is finally obeying a landmark
2016 decision by the canadian human
rights tribunal which found the federal
government has for years been
discriminating against indigenous
children this is not a final deal it
still needs approval but it's hoped
money will be distributed before the end
of 2022 david again has our top story
tonight on the deal and the reaction
this historic settlement of 40 billion
dollars has been a long time coming it
has been decades in fact in the making
but an agreement in principle now exists
to provide billions in compensation for
the harm done to tens of thousands of
first nations kids removed from their
home and placed in foster care and
billions more to prevent such harm from
ever happening again for the first time
math and science will dictate the
numbers this is what it costs to deliver
child and family services in our
communities ottawa will pay out at least
forty thousand dollars and possibly more
to an estimated 110 000 first nations
children and their families removed from
their home anytime after 1991 up until
now and placed in foster care this
wasn't and isn't about parenting it's in
fact about poverty and first nations
children being removed from their
families and communities instead of
being provided help with food clothing
or shelter similar payments of at least
forty thousand dollars will also be made
to the estimated
sixty thousand first nations children
who had medical treatment denied or
delayed because of federal provincial
squabbling over who should pay for that
care and no amount of money will ever be
the right amount nor will it bring back
a childhood lost but today is about
acknowledgement about being seen and
heard payment details will be worked out
over the months ahead and while all
parties hope to have the checks sent out
by the end of this year one of the
advocates who started the lawsuits will
be watching closely to make sure this
agreement in principle still subject to
court approval becomes a done deal we
owe it to the survivors and the youth in
care and the families who were told
their kid wasn't worth the money to see
this thing through to completion ottawa
also set aside close to 20 billion
additional dollars over the next five
years to improve child welfare services
in first nations communities much of
that money is expected to be used to
build new housing that it's not just
good for indigenous people it's good for
uh it's good for the country the future
of this country when every single person
has a fair chance to succeed now even as
ottawa puts this case behind it there
are other legal matters involving
indigenous plaintiffs still outstanding
including a suit by 105 first nations
who seek compensation for harm done to
their entire communities by the
residential school system donna
all right david aiken in ottawa thanks
well for years the federal government
argued in court it had no duty to
compensate first nations families or
children who were harmed by the
discriminatory child welfare system the
lead plaintiff in the first national
class action lawsuit to challenge that
was xavier mushum an algonquin from the
laksimon anishinaabe nation in quebec
today his lawyer honored him
i'd like to say a special word about the
young man whose name is attached to this
historic case
xavier mushroom xavier mushroom in
english when he was nine years old he
was removed from his family for reasons
which he still does not know
and placed into foster care
from the age of 9 until 18
xavier was transferred to 14
different foster homes
he was placed and he was removed from 14
different foster homes
he lost his native algonquin language
his culture and his ties to the laximo
community xavier trusted us to tell his
story in the hope that this lawsuit
would help change a discriminatory
system and provide financial support to
the children who suffered under it
now to the pandemic and the impact of
the omicron variant more than 11 000 new
cases were confirmed in ontario today
and as ontarians prepare for sweeping
new restrictions that come into force
tomorrow toronto's mayor is planning for
a worst case scenario anticipating the
peak of the omicron wave is still four
to six weeks away
i want people to know we are laser
focused on making sure that the
essential and critical city services
that residents rely on continue to be
delivered
the health care system throughout the
greater toronto area is already feeling
the strain two hospitals have moved to
code orange both because of rising cases
but also a shortage of staff who have
tested positive and stayed home as jamie
morocco explains that will impact all
patients not just those with covid
inside this brampton ontario hospital it
can feel like omicron is everywhere it's
causing widespread staffing shortages
and a sharp increase in covet patients
for a system already shorthanded it's
now a crisis i think it is the single
most important issue that is facing the
health care system in ontario at the
moment
it's forced brampton civic hospital and
etobicoke general to call a code orange
under the emergency measure staff will
be redeployed emergent care will be
prioritized and patients will be
transferred elsewhere a code orange is a
call to action not only for the hospital
and the health care workers but really
for the community at large an urgent
call to mask up keep your distance and
get necessary second and third doses but
no precaution is perfect and no hospital
is immune todd else is a nurse at a
toronto trauma center and says his er
too is dangerously short-handed we have
limited resources to isolate people and
so you're seeing patients that are
potentially coveted that are not being
isolated because we just simply don't
have the room
in quebec covert related staff shortages
have officials preparing for the worst
as well in the next two weeks most
surgeries are going to be canceled most
clinics are going to be canceled we're
talking about closing some some
emergency department the ambulatory
sites a hospital northeast of edmonton
already made the move to suspend labor
and delivery services and in manitoba
where covent hospitalizations are
surging the lack of frontline nurses
forced the temporary closure of two
northern hospitals there's no question
the patients who don't have covet are
also going to feel the effects of a very
strained healthcare system
strain that's always been there further
exposed by the pandemic it's a problem
that affects every canadian but one with
no immediate solution as omicron's
impact deepens jamie morocco global news
toronto
today prime minister justin trudeau
joined the ranks of canadians who have
had a booster dose of vaccine trudeau
flashed a thumbs up after getting his
third shot today he urged canadians to
do the same though access to boosters
varies depending on where you live
boosters are key to how we're going to
get through the next year with covid
evidence is emerging in other countries
that suggests the dramatic spike in
omicron cases could quickly burn itself
out as erik sorensen explains some
health experts believe omicron may be
the turning point to downgrading kovid
from a pandemic to a virus that's
endemic
bianca garibaldi and thousands of other
canadians have braved long lines and
frigid weather as omicron spreads both
the virus and a sense of urgency across
the country it's a little cold but it's
worth it to try to get a booster our
numbers are rising our icus are filling
up and it is absolutely
critical that we protect ourselves and
each other as covet case numbers rise
hospitalizations are edging upwards but
looking ahead there are signs of better
days to come omicron variant has indeed
spread quickly and exponentially the
risk of overwhelming our health care
system is real however as more canadians
contract omicron and get over it along
with increased protection from booster
vaccines it could result in a wall of
immunity that we have not produced up to
now this wave has risen faster than any
other but if it peaks then comes down
perhaps within weeks the large waves of
this pandemic could be more manageable
the virus eventually becoming endemic
something we live with like other
viruses this will be the game changer
the concerns that we had before you know
that we have big waves that overwhelm
the health care system
should not be there anymore at least not
to the same extent rather way rather
than waves we will have ripples omicron
became dominant in denmark before
christmas
yet that country's chief epidemiologist
now suggests the virus could subside
there in two months
the economy faces another bruising
winter but some businesses are looking
ahead one u.s airline is confident air
travel will bounce back by this summer
covent is now endemic we're getting
better as a society at dealing with it
accepting it and figuring out how to
manage and live our lives safely this
winter will be difficult more
restrictions more illness more deaths
but omicron may be the right formula to
see our way out of it by producing a
mild disease with lower mortality
by being much more transmissible than
other variants thereby out competing
them it's moving itself into potentially
becoming an endemic virus there is still
reason to worry about new variants
emerging but as society's immunity
builds naturally and with vaccines there
is reason for optimism too eric sorensen
global news toronto
another new variant with multiple
mutations has been discovered in france
though the world health organization
today downplayed the threat from it
french scientists say it was detected
last month in 12 people living near the
southern city of marseille they claimed
the first case was linked to a person
who had recently traveled from cameroon
variant has 46 mutations raising
concerns it could be more transmissible
possibly more resistant to vaccines the
findings though have not been peer
reviewed and the who monitors multiple
variants it's investigating this one but
has not declared it a variant of concern
in the u.s it took nearly four months
after the novel coronavirus first
emerged for that country to record one
million cases
now it's reporting that many in a single
day more than 1 million 82 000 new cases
were reported monday the first time any
country has reported a daily count that
high it's more than double the seven day
rolling average in the u.s the u.s
centers for disease control says omicron
accounts for 94.5 percent of cases and
hospitalizations are slowly rising too
in china it only took three confirmed
cases of copen 19 to impose a total
lockdown on a second city more than a
million people in yuju are under orders
not to leave home all three cases were
asymptomatic local officials say the
source of the infection is unknown but
there could be more in the city of xi'an
about 500 kilometers to the west went
into lockdown nearly two weeks ago its
13 million residents are banned from
leaving their homes and even need
verified proof of a negative test before
seeking medical services at hospitals
china has a zero covid policy and it's
trying to contain omicron ahead of the
2022 winter olympics which get underway
in beijing in one month
she was once the darling of silicon
valley coming up the dramatic downfall
of elizabeth holmes plus the criminal
charge former new york governor andrew
cuomo no longer faces
[Music]
well the first year of the pandemic
wasn't a bad one for canada's wealthiest
ceos in 2020 they had their second best
year ever the canadian center for policy
alternatives says the average pay for
canada's top 100 ceos at publicly traded
companies was 10.9 million dollars in
2020 that's up 95 000 from 2019 more
than 82 percent of the average came
through bonuses including cash and stock
options and about one-third of ceos who
got bonuses in 2020 worked for companies
which received government aid such as
the canada emergency wage subsidy
canada's top ceos made
191 times more than the average worker
in 2020 and as a final kicker the report
says by noon today they will have
already earned what the average canadian
makes
all year
the conviction of elizabeth holmes
former ceo of thoranos is a stunning
fall from grace after a three-month
trial a jury found her guilty on four
counts of fraud and she's gone from
being famous as the world's youngest
self-made woman billionaire to being
remembered for massively defrauding
investors
jackson proskow reports
she was once one of the most sought
after figures in silicon valley on
monday elizabeth holmes left court
convicted of fraud i believe
the individual
is the answer
to the challenges of health care as ceo
of theronos the company she founded at
age 19 holmes promised to revolutionize
medicine
with technology that could test for
hundreds of health problems with the
prick of a finger and a few drops of
blood
faster than traditional lab tests at a
fraction of the price every time you
create something new there should be
questions and
to me that's a sign that you've actually
done something that
is transformative how are you doing
skeptics quickly turned into investors
won over by who they thought was the
next tech profit like apple's steve jobs
right down to the black turtleneck she
is this
charismatic young college dropout she's
a woman in a world that is dominated by
male ceos billionaires like rupert
murdoch and national chains like safeway
and walgreens all bought in
at one point theranos became valued at
nearly 10 billion dollars people were
drawn in by both her and by her promises
to change the world in a way that wasn't
just building an app or social network
it was actually supposed to do something
transformative there was just one
problem the technology didn't work
the house of cards came crashing down
when holmes was indicted in 2018.
during her trial holmes testified in her
own defense
the jury heard evidence that sealed her
fate there was an investor call that was
taped where she was making statements
you know representations that turned out
to be false holmes now faces the
prospect of decades in prison her
ex-boyfriend theranos president sunny
bolwani faces his own trial on charges
of fraud
from the ashes of theranose has come a
reckoning for tech speculators a lesson
that the next big thing must first be
proven or it may turn out to be nothing
at all
jackson prosco global news washington
[Music]
ahead a dangerous u.s storm leaves
hundreds of drivers stuck in the snow
this freeway in the u.s state of
virginia is still a mess emergency crews
have been working to get drivers off
interstate 95 where hundreds were stuck
since monday the biggest snowstorm to
hit the mid-atlantic us in years upended
the commute of thousands stranding
drivers in temperatures around minus
eight degrees celsius the problems began
monday morning with a crash involving
six tractor trailers about 90 kilometers
south of washington dc virginia senator
tim kaine was among those stuck for 27
hours in what is normally a two-hour
drive to dc he said all he had was an
orange and a dr pepper many people were
were without food and water some ran out
of gas over 30 centimeters of snow
caused power outages and downed trees
and parts of the i-95 are still closed
former new york governor andrew cuomo
won't face criminal prosecution over an
allegation he groped in aid the district
attorney in albany says the accuser is
credible but that there's not enough
evidence to bring the case to court
cuomo who was due to face the charge in
court on friday has denied the
allegations he resigned as governor in
august after public pressure related to
multiple misconduct claims a new york
attorney general's report found he had
sexually harassed 11 women
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is the fairmont chateau laurier
hotel in ottawa which first opened back
in 1912. we'd love to see your canada
please email your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye
[Music]
you